OKAY, THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING, WE HAVE ONE BILL
ON TODAY'S AGENDA THAT IS AB 12.
OH FIVE FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER KHN. IT HAS BEEN PULLED
BACK FOR HEARING BECAUSE IT WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED. JUST
YESTERDAY. IS NOW RELATED TO
EDUCATION. AND OUR COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR GLAZER IS GOING TO BE
GOOD ENOUGH TO PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
HOPEFULLY HE'S FAMILIAR WITH THE
BILL. WHILE THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THIS COMMITTEE IS HEARING
THIS BILL, WE'VE ACTUALLY HEARD
ITS CONTENTS BEFORE IN THE FORM
OF SB 1200 FROM NO OTHER THAN
SENATOR GLAZER, SEEING NO
QUORUM, WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS
A SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE, SENATOR
GLAZER. GOOD MORNING. WELCOME.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. CHAIR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MEMBERS, FOR
BEING HERE. THANK YOU FOR MY
WITNESSES. THERE'S SOME CALLING
IN RIGHT NOW, YOU DON'T DO THAT
ANYMORE. FIRST TIME CALLER. LOVE
THE SHOW, MEMBERS, THIS IS A
FAMILIAR BILL. I KNOW TO MANY OF
YOU, I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN FOR PICKING
UP THE MANTLE TO BRING THIS
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE, I HOPE,
LET ME JUST, IN BRIEF SHARE WITH
YOU WHAT I THINK MANY OF YOU
KNOW THAT THIS BILL EXTENDS THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM,
WHICH I ESTABLISHED THROUGH
LEGISLATION IN 2016, THAT
PROGRAM QUITE SIMPLY GIVES THE
OPTION TO STUDENTS. IT'S AN
OPTION THAT IF THEY WANT TO TRY
TO GET ON A FOUR YEAR OR A TWO
YEAR TRACK FOR GRADUATION, THAT
THEY MAKE A COMMITMENT TO TAKE
THE APPROPRIATE UNITS THAT ARE
REQUIRED. IN EXCHANGE FOR THAT,
THEY ARE GIVEN PRIORITY
REGISTRATION AND SOME ACADEMIC
ADVISEMENT HELP, AND THEY HAVE
TO COMPLETE THE UNIT
REQUIREMENT. AS I MENTIONED,
SINCE THE PROGRAM WAS ENACTED,
ALONG WITH SO MANY OTHER
IMPORTANT REFORMS THAT THE CSU
HAS INSTITUTED, THERE'S BEEN
REAL IMPROVEMENT IN THE FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE IN 2015.
THAT RATE WAS 19%. GRADUATING IN
FOUR YEARS. TODAY, IT'S 38%. SO
SYSTEM WIDE THROUGH A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS, INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE OR FINISH IN
FOUR, WE'VE SEEN REALLY GREAT
PROGRESS. AND LET ME JUST
MENTION, BECAUSE THE CHAIR AND I
WERE IN HIS DISTRICT THIS SPRING
AT FULLERTON, MEETING WITH
CAMPUS LEADERSHIP ABOUT THE
PROGRAM THERE. AND I THOUGHT
THAT ONE OF THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY, FACTS THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO US WAS THAT THOSE
WHO WERE IN THE FOUR YEAR
PROGRAM AT FULLERTON HAD A 93%
GRADUATION RATE. 93%, WHICH IS
TWO AND A HALF TIMES HIGHER THAN
THE UNIVERSITY AVERAGE. SO IT'S
AN INDICATION THAT IF STUDENTS
KNOW THAT THERE'S A PATHWAY FOR
THEM TO GET THROUGH LESS DEBT
AND ACHIEVE THEIR OBJECTIVES
MORE QUICKLY, THAT THEY ARE
EXCITED ABOUT BEING A PART OF
THAT EFFORT. SO THIS BILL
EXTENDS THAT PROGRAM. THERE WAS
A SUNSET ENDING IN JANUARY 1ST
OF 2026. AND IN ADDITION TO
THAT, IT DOES REQUIRE SOME
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS SO THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN BE MORE
INFORMED ABOUT HOW THE PROGRAM
IS BEING USED, IT CHANGES ITS
NAME TO FINISH IN FOUR OR
THROUGH IN TWO, BECAUSE THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE NAME HAS NOW
BECOME MORE UNIVERSALLY USED IN
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
AND SO THAT'S THE SHORT SUMMARY
OF WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO. AND
WITH THAT, HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. YOU DO NOT
HAVE A PRIORITY WITNESS OR WE
ALSO. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE ARE THERE,
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? ALSO
SEEING NONE. COMING BACK TO ME
HERE AT THE DAIS. SO I ACTUALLY
DO APPRECIATE THIS. SUPPORTED
YOUR ORIGINAL MEASURE WHEN IT
CAME THROUGH. I WANT TO GIVE YOU
CREDIT FOR YOUR PERSPICACITY IN
STAYING ON TOP OF THIS AND
ACTUALLY SEEING IT THROUGH. AND
SO I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT AB. 1205,
AND WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM.
SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE OR ASK
YOURSELF QUESTIONS AS A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE, PLEASE DO SO
NOW JUST TO SAY THIS, THAT THERE
ARE A FEW PROGRAMS IN STATE
GOVERNMENT WITH WITH VERY LITTLE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES, YOU'VE
DOUBLED PRODUCTIVITY. AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PROVIDED SOME
ENHANCED FUNDS TO THE
UNIVERSITY, BUT A VERY, VERY
SMALL AMOUNT. AND IN THE COURSE
OF THAT, WITH THE DEDICATED WORK
OF THE UNIVERSITY LEADERSHIP AND
THE FACULTY AND STAFF, YOU HAVE
NOW A DOUBLE DOUBLING OF AN
OUTCOME. AND IT'S PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY IN STATE
GOVERNMENT TO FIND ANY PLACE
WHERE YOU'VE EVER SEEN THAT
BEFORE. SO I KNOW THAT IT DOES
FORCE A BUREAUCRACY TO ADJUST TO
STUDENT NEEDS. AND SO THAT
DOESN'T ALWAYS MAKE PEOPLE
HAPPY, THE FOCUS OF THE PROGRAM
IS ON UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS.
I DIDN'T MENTION THAT EARLIER.
THAT'S THE FOCUS ON WHO IS
PROVIDED THE PRIORITY TO BE IN
THE PROGRAM, AND FINALLY, LET ME
JUST MENTION A BLEMISH IN THIS
PROGRAM. IT'S WORTH NOTING
BECAUSE I THINK EVERYONE
REALIZES IT, BUT DOESN'T LIKE
NECESSARILY TO TALK ABOUT IT,
THAT THE GAP BETWEEN
UNDERREPRESENTED AND THE STUDENT
BODY AS A WHOLE CONTINUES TO BE
PERSISTENT. I TALK ABOUT HOW WE
DOUBLED THE GRADUATION RATE, BUT
THAT GAP STILL EXISTS, AND IT'S
A PART OF WHY THIS PROGRAM IS
IMPORTANT AND WHY I HOPE YOU'LL
ADVANCE IT. TODAY AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN.
THANK YOU. LET ME JUST ADD, I'M
SORRY I SHOULD HAVE EARLIER, BUT
I DO THINK YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN THAT FOR UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY, IT IS
OVERWHELMING MAKING THAT
TRANSITION INTO COLLEGE. AND THE
MORE THEY KNOW THE BETTER THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO RESOURCES, THE
MORE LIKELY THEY ARE GOING TO
MAKE DECISIONS AND ACCESS
RESOURCES TO GET TO GRADUATION.
THE ABSENCE OF THOSE RESOURCES
EXPLAINS IN MANY WAYS WHY THEY
HAVE SO MANY CHALLENGES. SO
AGAIN, THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT
HERE IS MEANINGFUL, GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU,
SIR, AND WE WILL TAKE THIS UP.
AND WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE WILL
VOTE ON IT FROM THERE. LOOK,
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS FOR NOW
UNTIL WE GET TWO MORE MEMBERS
HERE.
LET US NOW RECONVENE THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. SENATOR
CORTEZ. GOOD MORNING, MADAM. WE
DO NOW APPEAR TO HAVE A QUORUM.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. NEWMAN. HERE. HERE. OCHOA
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. HERE. GLASER.
GLASER. HERE. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. HERE. WILK. A QUORUM IS
INDEED PRESENT. WE DO NEED A
MOTION ON AB 1205, WHICH SENATOR
GLASER PRESENTED ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER. KHN.
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE THE MOTION.
SENATOR GLASER MAKES THE MOTION.
ALL RIGHT, SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I'LL ITEM ONE, AB
1205. BAUER KHN MOTION IS DUE.
PASS PREFERS TO BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. I OTOBOKE CORTEZ,
I CORTEZ I GLASER. YEAH. GLASER.
NO GLASER. NO. TO I ABOUT TO
CLOSE THE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I WILK.
WILK. WE'RE VOTING ON THE BILL.
YES. HI. WILK I THAT MEASURE
PASSES BY A RESOUNDING FIVE
VOTES TO ZERO. THANK YOU. ALL. I
DO HAVE 30 MINUTES OF PREPARED
REMARKS THANKING SENATORS GLASER
AND WILK FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION
ON THIS COMMITTEE. BUT WE COULD
DO THIS AT SOME OTHER POINT. SO
WITH THAT, THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.